Let's discuss the solution
to our TLB performance quiz.
We have a one megabyte array that
we are reading one byte at a time.
One megabyte is 2 to the 20th bytes.
Our page is 4 kilobytes,
which is 2 to the 12th.
So there are 256 pages in this array.
Now what happens is,
once you have the first access,
you will have a level one TLB miss.
A level two will be missed and
the translation will be generated and
placed in both TLB's.
Next, when we access the second byte,
we have a TLB hit because that byte is
in the same page as the previous one.
So after the first miss
we will have hits for
the remainder of the four kilobyte page.
In the first sweep we will
have 256 L1 TLB misses,
cause that's how many pages we accessed,
and we will have 4095.
This is one less than four kilobytes,
times 256.
They'll be hits at L1.
After this first sweep, the Level 1 TLB
contains the entries for the second half
of the array, because the array needs
256 pages, we only have 128- entry.
The level two TLB, however,
contains the mappings for
the entire array because it's still
has enough elements to hold them.
So what's going to happen after the
first sweep, is the level one TLB will
continue doing this 256 hits and
this many misses each time we sweep,
but the level two TLB will
start hitting all the time.
So what we have is ten times
two-fifty-six misses here and
ten times 4095 times 256 hits here.
Now the question is for
L2 what do we have?
We know that we will have 256 misses,
that is because during
the first sweep we have no mappings for
any of the 256 pages.
After the first sweep We will have
the mapping for all the pages so
we will only have hits, but
the question is how many of them?
Well know that we only
access the level two TLB
if we have a miss in the level one TLB.
So the number of hits here will
be this minus this, so for
nine sweeps we will be having
these Misses go here and big hits.
So this is the answer to this quiz.